[Applause]
thank you thank you very much thank you
all for being here Thank You Patricia
for organizing this it is true indeed
the idea of having this event in the
occasion of my visit here in Japan the
second in a month in the occasion of the
g20 foreign ministers meeting came out
of a conversation we had just less than
one month ago and we thought that the
excellent bilateral relationship we have
between the European Union and Japan
could have also been deepened and
showcased on this very important topic
of the role of women and young people in
the peace and security work globally
because we are partners on trade with
partners on political issues between the
European Union and Japan but we're also
partners in society and were also
partners in the global work we do to
advance a peace and security agenda that
can be inclusive and probably
sustainable involving fully young people
and and women I would like to thank you
all for being here for making this
possible because we are not just to
discuss a specific policy or program
today although of course we also need
the right policies and programs and this
is why I'm so honored and happy to have
with us today some of the key
decision-makers here in Japan members of
parliament and Minister corner that is
joining us in a few minutes but we are
here to discuss a global change of
mindset embodied by two UN Security
Council resolutions that are at the
heart of the foreign and security policy
for sure of the European Union and I
believe also of Japan a pretty radical
change of mindset the international
community finally accepted collectively
that women and youth are not just the
object of our policies the recipients of
decisions that are taken by others and
these others are often men and often
over 60 years old women and young people
are agents of change
in their lives in their friendships and
the relationships in their families in
their communities in the countries and
also globally if we don't recognize this
if we don't acknowledge this fact we
condemn our policies and our actions to
being ineffective it is as simple as
that we are here first and foremost
because we recognize a fact a reality in
our societies in our countries in the
21st century you have all seen some
images that have I believe inspired us
all you've seen the images of a Sudanese
young woman standing on the top of a car
asking for democracy in our country the
colder the Sudanese Statute of Liberty
and I just met the new prime minister of
Sudan a few weeks ago in Brussels in
hornaday's with a visit and that change
came about and started from there
from participation from active
participation of a young woman we all
know about the leading role of our sons
and daughters in the global movement for
climate action without them that key
policy issue would probably not be at
the forefront of the political landscape
globally across the world young people
are the majority in many of the
societies and of course women are half
of the global population in these years
I've had the honour of meeting many of
those people there are the leading force
behind women peace and security and
youth peace and security I will only
mention the former Colombian children
soldiers who finally had access to
education when the war in the country
ended the Syrian and Yemeni women were
working with the United Nations with the
support of the European Union to try to
build peace and reconciliation in the
countries because there is no real peace
and security without them peace deals
are usually signed by two men the two
leaders of the two sides at war this
might begin
with that signature that is a key
starting point but that signature is
never enough to build peace on the
ground for real peace can only grow and
stand the test of time
if it has deep roots in the societies
that have been in conflict and for this
you need youth and women without them
there's no peace you need the silent
majority and you need the silent
majority to become less silent to engage
because this majority was not just a
victim of war or a hostage rather of war
this majority can be the agents of
change and moving from war conflicts
tensions to peace requires deep changes
the most powerful agent of peace and
reconciliation in societies are always
women and young people at the same is
true to prevent conflicts before they
arise a country will be much less stable
if it's young people cannot find a
decent job or cannot express their ideas
freely if they don't find their place in
society I have always been impressed by
my dialogue for instance with young
generation in some of the Arab countries
and when I asked them why do you think
your people your age your generation
sometimes are attracted by becoming a
foreign fighter in another country or
attracted by the - ideology they often
told me it's not just a matter of
economy or having a job it's a matter of
having a place in the organic gram of
society of being part of something
belonging somewhere and I think this
element of inclusion of giving a role to
play to each and every one of us is a
key component also of preventing
violence and conflict in the same way
violence against women includes many
different forms from economic injustice
to social disparities lack of fairer
healthcare as well as physical mental
emotional
violence against mainly women and girls
and when a society is not just there can
be no sustainable peace either there are
policies that we can put in place to
address this imbalances policies to give
our young people and women the
opportunities that they serve and also
that our societies need or to involve
women and youth in a peace process but
beyond changing policies which is
essential we need a change of attitudes
which implies also an individual effort
we need to teach our boys and girls that
violence is always wrong that violence
is not a demonstration of strength but
rather the opposite is always a
demonstration of weakness and those that
take violent attitudes especially
against women and girls are actually
showing their weakness it's simply not
cool I think this should be the message
that our young boys in particular should
reflect in their behaviors and their our
relations with their peers and we need
to stop thinking that by opening our
decision-making to youth and women we're
doing them a favor I'm convinced that
we're doing a favor to all of us and in
particular we're doing a favor to our
democracies because if a democracy is
not able to reflect the composition of
the population if the voters are not
able to identify themselves in those
that are being elected that is a
weakness for our democratic systems this
is the only way to make decision-making
really inclusive and also sustainable I
believe and it's also the only way to
really give peace a chance so we will
continue to work with Japan with all of
you to change our collective attitudes
that start with our individual behaviors
and to do it together and to recognize
youth and women as true fundamental
agents of change to support them not
just because they need it but because
the entire society needs that I thank
you very much
[Applause]